out of the uk where britain's prime
minister boris johnson is under more
pressure from his political opponents
and some people in his own party to
resign a new report lays out the facts
of a series of parties that johnson and
other officials held here's the problem
during a national lockdown
some information from that report is now
also part of a police investigation
mts taeyab has more now from london on a
bruising showdown in parliament for
johnson
sorry
and i'm sorry for the things we simply
didn't get right and also sorry for the
way that this matter has been handled
[Applause]
the back and forth in this great chamber
of democratic debate was as boisterous
as ever
and at times brutal but prime minister
the british public aren't fools they
never believed a word of it
they think the prime minister should do
the decent thing and resign
johnson insists he isn't going anywhere
but the initial findings of a
long-awaited government report into at
least 12 parties while britain was in
lockdown doesn't look good for the prime
minister
it found there was too little thought
given to what was happening failures of
leadership and excessive consumption of
alcohol the mat is now investigating the
full details of that report won't be
made public until the police's criminal
investigation is complete but according
to the police they've received over 500
pages of evidence at at least 300 photos
some of them taken after the prime
minister made this visit to a school on
his birthday
one cake apparently not enough
he was served another by several
colleagues inside the cabinet room at 10
downing street prime minister take
responsibility but the party's over for
johnson says conservative lawmaker
andrew bridget
should boris johnson resign
boris johnson and the clique around him
apparently have been able to do what
they want while telling the rest of the
country
to do as they're told that's not
acceptable
now boris johnson is on his way to the
ukraine this morning far away from his
troubles at home but consider this
former conservative prime minister david
cameron once described johnson and i'm
quoting here as a greased piglet someone
who can wriggle his way out of just
about anything question now is can you
wriggle out of this one too
nate
we'll have to wait and find out they
have a way with words
politics over in the uk you're right
about that mts in london thank you so
much